[Music]
jonathan who joins us in louisville
kentucky jonathan how can we help
hey good afternoon gentlemen how y'all
doing today we are living the dream
what's going on glad to hear it okay so
this is my situation so
i'm trying to get everything in order i
bought a house last october um the first
year is coming up so i'm trying to get
everything squared away with the 15-year
plan to have it paid off
but i still have a little bit of debt i
have about eight thousand dollars that i
owe on my car
and i have about
six thousand dollars in credit card debt
so i'm thinking about just paying it all
off so i can just focus on my house and
i'm just i don't know if that's a smart
move or not because i don't want to
you know if i need an escape though for
my faith for my savings i don't want to
you know put myself in a twist at the
end of the day
put yourself in a twist i like that turn
of phrase jonathan well let me start
with this do you know the baby steps
that we teach
yes
so we teach you to first have that
thousand dollar starter emergency fund
and then tackle the debt then get that
fully funded emergency fund and then we
move to 3b where we save for the house
so it sounds like maybe there was some
things done out of order here and that's
okay we can clean this mess up but how
much do you have in savings
about 35 000 35 000
yes how much of that is your actual
emergency fund how much do you need for
three to six months of expenses
uh give or take
five six thousand
total for your three to six months
emergency fund yes oh yes like like six
seven thousand yes well that leaves us
with some really good news if you have
35k in there and you only need seven for
the emergency fund you can pay off all
your debts hold on a second george
uh jonathan are you telling me that
three months expenses is seven thousand
dollars for you
yes oh my mortgage is yes okay i just
want to make sure that yeah really not
three months i'm sorry about about four
about four to five months about four to
five not seven thousand and three months
more like four to five months okay uh so
something's still not adding up so
your monthly expenses are about what
twelve hundred dollars what are you
running with the mortgage and everything
to keep the lights on feed yourself
13.50 for the mortgage uh about another
what is it about
about another grand for the expenses for
the house so two four six
yeah that's about right yeah that's
about right six seven thousand dollars
oh so you're saying six or seven per
month
for expenses yeah okay so we need to
multiply that out to 10 times three to
get to three to six months of expenses
so the answer to the question uh is 21
000 minimum jonathan
that's what you're pretty much yet
which is perfect because you just told
me you've got 14 000 in debt and you
need 21 for the emergency fund so to me
you make the calls as soon as you're off
the phone with us you go pay off that
credit card you go pay off that car loan
which is going to free up a whole bunch
of money for you to actually pay off
this house in 15 years or less does that
sound right gotcha it does yes okay and
i want to make sure you're also
investing 15 percent of your income into
retirement have you begun that
i have but i'm not doing 15. i'm at 10
right now and then with the uh with the
401 k 10 percent in that as well so okay
normally i'd tell you to pause the
investing but because you're going to
pay off this debt today i'm not
concerned with that what i want you to
do though is before you start attacking
the house pay off all this debt today
increase that investing to 15
of your household income total into a
good retirement account depending on
your situation maybe an ira or 401k roth
if you've got either those options and
then whatever margin is left over throw
at the house and pay this thing off i
think you can do it in less than 10
years you seem like a hard-working guy
definitely but so i mean i make you know
seventy thousand dollars a year i feel
like i can afford it it's just hard to
let i guess let go of the money you know
i mean that's a lot of money so it's
just kind of hard to let it go oh i get
it but you know what what else is hard
looking at those payments disappear from
your bank account every month instead of
going to you to your goals so i think
you've you've got a few things backwards
we got so much going for you jonathan
and i want you to do things in order
that's what we teach is the baby steps
so pay off all this debt today clean
this mess up get to 15 and then you'll
be paying off that house with total
freedom and no payments in the world
yeah it's gonna feel so much better
jonathan you just got to focus on the
big picture not the immediate and so
what happens is george somebody's got a
lot of money in his case 35 000 in the
bank right and so the immediate focus
it's just kind of like
tunnel thinking oh man it's 35 000. i
don't want to cut a check today for 14
grand and watch that drop to 21 or
whatever it's emotional it is emotional
but the big picture is wait a second
let's get outside of that a bank account
and go what does this do when i pay off
this debt
and how it fast-forwards everything he's
making good money now he's through baby
step four and now he's just rocking yeah
and people don't understand the momentum
that you get when you do the steps in
order because jonathan you're trying to
do a lot at once right now you're trying
to pay off the debt you're trying to
invest you're trying to pay off the
house and what happens is you lose steam
because you go i can't do it none of
it's really moving i'm not moving the
needle so once you start doing this
stuff in order you're going to gain a
ton of traction and you've got a great
income to get that done yeah